trois deux un top les chronomètres sont
lancés depuis le 1er janvier tous les
médias audiovisuels doivent décompter le
temps de parole des candidats déclarés
ou présumées à la présidentielle
le principe date de 1965 année de la
première élection au suffrage universel
direct alain peyrefitte ministre de
l'information expliquer les règles en
direct à la télévision à partir de 19
novembre début de la campagne légale si
vous préférez
les candidats pourront développer leurs
arguments pendant des tranches horaires
d'un total de 2 heures à la radio et de
deux heures à la télévision pour chacun
sous réserve que les candidats ne se
multiplient patron le pluralisme
politique à la télévision et à la radio
devenait donc la règle et depuis 1989
c'est le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel le csa qui veille au
respect du temps de parole pour chaque
candidat une véritable cellule
d'observation
ces deux femmes ont un rôle fondamental
elles sont chargées d'évaluer
l'équilibré des temps de parole
politique sur chaque antenne tout est
mesuré chaque mot est pesé à la lettre
le décompte du temps de parole est
divisé en deux périodes jusqu'à la
veille de la campagne officielle soit
deux semaines avant le premier tour les
chaînes et les radios doivent respecter
le principe d'équité entre les candidats
en fonction de leur représentativité et
de leur implication dans la campagne en
2012 christine kelly membre du csa et
persie c'est ce principe l'équité veut
que plus on a eu de bonnes élections de
bottes de bons résultats lors des
dernières élections plus on est
représenté
si on ne fait rien on n'est pas
représenté si on fait un petit peu on
est peu représentée donc ça laisse de la
souplesse à la chaîne et à la radio en
fonction de certains critères de bon
sens de représenter plus ou moins un
candidat ensuite on passe à la stricte
égalité jusqu'à la veille du premier
tour la stricte égalité du temps de
parole et la deuxième période du
décompte imposées aux médias
audiovisuels le poids politique des
candidats n'entrent plus en ligne de
compte la durée des interventions comme
les horaires de diffusion doivent être
les mêmes pour tous et les commentaires
des journalistes sont aussi
comptabiliser le ton dans son viseur
nicolas sarkozy l'a par exemple c'était
un look un journaliste qui s'exprimait
pour par les différents candidats
s'élancent du temps journalistiques tout
à l'heure dans lesquels vérité j'avais
nathalie arthaud nathalie arthaud c'est
donc du temps de parole directement
puisque c'est elle qui parle en son nom
en tant qu'homme dette en 2016 la
période d'égalité stripped du temps de
parole sur les antennes et passer de
cinq à deux semaines l'objectif
faciliter le suivi des dernières
semaines de campagne pour les médias
audiovisuels et la règle ne passait pas
pour tout le monde les petits partis
montait au créneau trois partis
dominants
monopoliseront l'expression publique
c'est la fin de l'égalité on n'a jamais
vu ça depuis la création de la
présidentielle pour la présidentielle
2022 l'égalité strict du temps de parole
sera du 28 mars au 9 avril veille du
premier tour le csa veillera au grain
sur les télés et les radios en revanche
les médias numériques tels que les
réseaux sociaux ne font pas partie du
décompte
[Musique]